mamma mia sono tutti così bravi qua a
parlare mi sento quasi un po una
contadina devo dire solo grazie sono
tamara lunger dell'alto adige e molto
spesso mi sento tanto fai di e quindi mi
sembra che la rai di non sta bene in
scarpe strette e a francoforte quindi ho
deciso di presentarmi oggi proprio come
sono e far questo mi tolgo anche le
scarpe
amo molto ad essere libera e quindi solo
li posso essere anche se dice vediamo
due alpinisti quali sapar e simone moro
sulla cima del nanga parbat 8.125 metri
inverno un'altra foto di nuovo a lisa
tara e alec c con sulla stessa cima
abbiamo il 26 febbraio 2016 ed è il
giorno della prima ascensione inverno
sulla vetta del nanga parbat che era uno
degli ultimi 28 mila che non era ancora
scalata d'inverno erano in tre
sulla cima e manca qualcuno che sono io
abbiamo fatto un viaggio veramente lungo
sono partita da bolzano dakar più o meno
casa mia
siamo andati al campo base del nanga
parbat che si trova su una quota di
4.100 metri anche se in totale sono più
o meno 50 ore di viaggio
e questo solo se tutto va bene perché
magari si sbuca una gomma magari si
rovina la macchina magari ci sono
problemi con
permette alla scalata o manca qualche
materiale quindi è sempre un po una cosa
imprevista e poi in questi 50 ore arrivi
in un posto totalmente diverso è un
altro mondo un'altra cultura un'altra
religione
un'altra temperatura e soprattutto un
altro comfort perché non abbiamo un
bagno riscaldato di al campo base
dobbiamo fare i nostri doveri in un buco
di neve e sciogliere la neve per lavarci
e così via
tutto questo dopo il viaggio sei
soltanto al campo base e lì senza con
forse nella tenda undici metri quadrati
con il tuo compagno di cordata in questo
caso era simone moro di bergamo e ci
abbiamo ci troviamo veramente bene ed è
anche molto necessario in una cosa così
perché 66 assieme 24 ore su 24
e tutto questo tra delle temperature del
frigo e del freezer
quindi non è la temperatura della stufa
a casa ma durante tutto questo tempo
avevo sempre questa frase dentro mia mio
cervello
andiamo in cima andiamo e ci va e
nonostante tutti questi giorni di attesa
che erano 61 giorni al campo base e in
totale la spedizione era 89 giorni non
ho mai perso questa speranza e sono
sempre stata positiva dopo 50 giorni di
attesa il campo base finalmente è
arrivato quel tempo bello
abbiamo aspettato a tutti e siamo
partiti dal campo base per andare in
vetta del nanga parbat questa montagna è
nono la montagna è la nona montagna del
mondo e darvi un'idea se fai l'everest
da nord partito e ibc che 6.200 metri e
fai 2.600 metri per arrivare in cima
su questa montagna fa e 4.000 metri di
dislivello dal campo base in cima quindi
è quasi il doppio
in più la nostra montagna più alta
d'europa il monte bianco sta dentro 40
volte nella caparbia quindi è
incredibile grande siamo partiti dal
campo base 4.100 metri
abbiamo saltato campo 1 perché ci
sentiamo forti e abbiamo fatto 2 mila
metri di dislivello per arrivare al
campo due per uno che è allenato super
bene qui dalle nostre quote se li fa in
due ore anche meno il più veloce del
mondo
gli fa magari in un'ora ma lì su queste
quote abbiamo fatto di 10 ore più o meno
poi abbiamo fatto un altro campo sul
campo 3 abbiamo fatto un'altra notte lì
e poi siamo andati al campo 4 che
l'ultima notte qui ma dalla cima ed è un
momento molto speciale perché hai
aspettato così la lungo e poi vedi la
cina è molto vicina ma anche molto
lontana perché non hai nessun punto di
riferimento ti mancano ancora mille
metri di salita e si deve contare con 10
ore circa 100 metri
le ho paura e poi a questa questo
incredibile panorama davanti a te e ti
senti soltanto orgogliosa perché sei una
delle poche o dei pochi nella storia che
avevano la fortuna di essere qua
l'inverno al campo 4 che si trova sul 7
mila 100 200 metri e poi siamo partiti
per la cima
prima ci siamo alzati verso le 4 del
mattino ci siamo preparati due ore
riscaldato le scarpe fatte dell'acqua e
preparato
i primi due alex e da lì sono partiti
verso le 6 estesa alle sei e trenta e
simone moro poi alle 650 è già lì ho
sentito che non mi sento così bene non
avevo il giorno giusto ma ero così
sicuro e che potevo andare in cima e
adesso vi faccio vedere veramente
l'unico video che ho fatto
lungo questa salita verso la cima che
era talmente freddo che non avevo voglia
di fare di più ma per me era il momento
più pieno di emozione perché abbiamo
aspettato pertanto finché ci va c'è il
sole è talmente freddo li che aspetti
solo il sole è certamente paolo in alto
atesino l'inail video e quindi vi faccio
adesso la traduzione ho detto adesso ho
aspettato per quattro ore che mi bacia
il sole e questo mi sa che vale qualche
lacrima
e talmente sulle dove avevamo meno 34
gradi e un vento di 45 km orari che sono
meno 58 gradi sotto zero di percepito
si sfascia
stephen j
se vedete a muovere gli altri sono quasi
fermi ma che si deve pensare che ogni
dieci passi si deve formare un minuto di
pausa quindi è tutto molto lento sia
tanto tempo per pensare durante la
salita e poi questo desiderio di scalare
questa montagna l'avevo già per un anno
poi abbiamo fatto tutto questo viaggio
abbiamo aspettato 55 giorni al campo
base e finalmente era questo momento
dove potevo andare in cima
poi mi sono trovato a 70 metri sotto la
cima e dovevo fare una decisione mi
sentivo vuota senza forza e ho vomitato
durante tutta la salita ma volevo tener
duro ea un certo punto mi è venuto un
flash nel cervello e mi ha detto se
adesso va in cima non ritorni più a casa
ed era talmente forte che non avevo
neanche un dubbio cosa fare o che so che
in questo momento ero proprio me stessa
ero al centro della mia personalità ero
a casa nel mio mondo perché amo a fare
fatica e a mo di essere così vicino al
limite delle mie forze
e poi non volevo mettere in rischio i
miei compagni perchè sapevo e ho bisogno
di un'altra ora per andare in cima se
loro mi aspettano poi diventa tutto
metto in rischi a tutti quindi sono
scesa e durante la discesa dove dovevo
veramente far attenzione per non cadere
perché era talmente ripido e dovevo
concentrarmi per arrivare bene al campo
4 a un certo punto devo dovevo saltare
un crepaccio
sono caduta sono caduta per 200 metri e
dopo i primi momenti della lotta contro
la morte
ho fatto la rinuncia dentro di me ho
detto adesso sono morta
vediamo quando mi arriva questo colpo
finale ma dopo 200 metri mi sono fermata
non so come mai come era possibile e
vedevo solo questo panorama ed era solo
mio era era così bello e potevo vivere
ancora questa emozione ma non era tanto
tempo per tutto questo perché dovevo
essere veloce per rientrare al campo 4
perché con queste condizioni non trovi
così facile le tracce perché sono dentro
solo le punte dei ramponi ed era una
zona pieno di crepacci quindi dovevo
essere veloce con tutti i dolori mi
avevo avuto due legamenti qua
così mi sono trascinata bene al campo 4
e ho aspettato i miei amici ma questa
rinuncia mi ha portato veramente tanta
ricchezza
già prima ho fatto delle rinunce su
altre cime e ho ricevuto la fiducia dei
miei genitori
poi ho rinunciato a un lavoro normale
con una paga normale ma la vita mi ha
regalato un mondo pieno di felicità e
soddisfazione di tanta avventura
e poi anche con questa rinuncia ho
capito che questo valore che io ho
portato a casa che era la consapevolezza
di questa voce interna che mi ha salvato
la vita e che lo farà ancora è molto più
importante dalla cima e poi siamo ci
sinceri a volte si rinuncia anche a un
ragazzo e aveva sempre uno migliore no
e adesso vi dico una cosa che lo sanno
solo in pochi che era veramente un
momento dove ero triste anche su questa
rinuncia che era il campo 4 dove mi
dovevo congratulare con i miei compagni
li volevo anche essere io congratulata
per la cima ma non era così
la notte poi al campo 4 era talmente
butta avevo male dappertutto avevo i
pensieri come posso scendere il giorno
dopo al campo base
perché lì non volano gli elicotteri 66
un po sola e quindi durante questa notte
questa tristezza si è trasformata in
totale felicità felicità per la mia
decisione e felicità per il successo dei
miei compagni e la grande lezione che ho
portato a casa di questa esperienza è
che nonostante la mia rinuncia solo con
un team forte e unito puoi arrivare in
cima dei tuoi sogni
grazie